[Música]
segundo día de ejercicios militares
chinos en el estrecho de Taiwán
maniobras ordenadas por Beijing como
advertencia hacia taipei tras el paso de
la presidenta taiwanesa por Estados
Unidos donde se reunió con el presidente
de la cámara de representantes
Israel ataca Siria en respuesta a los
cohetes lanzados desde territorio sirio
una escalada desatada por las redadas de
la policía israelí en la mezquita de
alaxa durante el ramadán el mes sagrado
de los musulmanes
se cumplen 20 años del derrocamiento de
sadán en el marco de la invasión
estadounidense de Irak que empezó el 20
de marzo de 2003 el líder iraquí fue
condenado a muerte y ejecutado tres años
más tarde
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
China que Avanza en sus ejercicios
militares en el estrecho de Taiwán con
estas maniobras a gran escala Beijing
lanza una nueva advertencia a taipei
después de la visita de la presidenta
taiwanés a Estados Unidos donde
recordemos se reunió con el presidente
de la cámara de representantes el
republicano Kevin mccarthy la respuesta
de Beijing en esta ecuación se
corresponde bastante con la que ya tuvo
en agosto del año pasado cuando la
entonces presidenta de la cámara la
demócrata Nancy pelosi visitó Taiwán
dos barcos de guerra cara a cara uno es
taiwanés el otro chino cada uno de ellos
está listo para disparar en cualquier
momento un claro indicio de las altas
tensiones entre las dos potencias en el
estrecho de Taiwán la televisión Estatal
china anunció el sábado simulacros
militares a gran escala del ejército
chino donde se movilizaron 71 aviones
militares y nueve buques de guerra
el objetivo ensayar un cerco completo de
Taiwán situado sobre los 130 kilómetros
de la costa China
Taiwán es una parte inseparable de China
desde el final de la Segunda Guerra
Mundial china se niega a reconocer la
independencia de Taiwán y considera La
Isla como parte de su propio territorio
una alianza que quedó patente a
principios de semana durante la visita
la presidenta taiwanesa California para
reunirse con el presidente de la cámara
de representantes
presencia y apoyo tranquilizar al pueblo
de Taiwán no nos sentimos solos
el apoyo de Estados Unidos a Taiwán es
un desafío para china ya que tiene
muchas bases militares en la región y ha
dicho que estaría dispuesto a defender a
Taiwán si china invadir a la isla el
presidente chino ha dicho que la
reunificación con Taiwán debe cumplirse
lo que hace temer que puede usar la
fuerza el riesgo a corto plazo de una
invasión es bajo y a día de hoy no hay
señales ni pruebas de que china se esté
preparando para ello sin embargo china
sigue aumentando significativamente sus
capacidades militares para tener más
poder en los próximos años lo que podría
cambiar el status quo y permitirle tomar
Taiwán por la fuerza
según Beijing los ejercicios militares
durarán tres días en total
vamos ahora Oriente medio Porque la
violencia en Jerusalén desborda una vez
más hacia los países de la región es que
Israel volvió a atacar Siria con
artillería y fuerza aérea llegando hasta
las afueras de la capital Damasco en
este caso según las autoridades
israelíes la ofensiva es una respuesta
al lanzamiento de seis cohetes de ese
territorio sirio hacia los altos del
golán una zona Siria ocupada por Israel
desde la guerra de 1967 nuestro
corresponsal para Israel y los
territorios palestinos Federico cué
Barberena nos contaba que más se sabe de
la última respuesta de israelí
Sí todo inició con dos tandas es de
cohetes lanzados desde Siria los
primeros desde 2019 hacia los altos del
golán en territorio anexionado por
Israel tres de esos proyectiles cayeron
en espacio abierto sin causar daños en
ni víctimas medios árabes indican que la
responsabilidad recae en una milicia
Palestina que opera en Siria y es aliada
del régimen de vallada y que es en
respuesta a las incursiones israelíes en
la mezquita de alaxa de ahí la respuesta
israelí que apuntó contra instalaciones
del ejército sirio porque en última
instancia lo responsabiliza de todo lo
que ocurra responsabiliza además o de lo
que ocurra en su territorio estos
ataques se fueron con artillería Y
drones no tripulados y e impactaron en
un complejo militar sistemas de radares
y de artillería en el sur de Siria
recordemos que Israel ha llevado a cabo
10 ataques en suero sirio en lo que va
de 2023 Pero estos habían sido contra
posiciones iraníes o de sus milicias
aliadas y no los discute públicamente A
diferencia de esta ofensiva en que
realizó una jornada de hoy
vamos ahora con información relativa a
la guerra en Ucrania las autoridades de
kiev informaron que las fuerzas rusas
mataron a un hombre de 50 años y a su
hija de 11 en un ataque con misiles
contra un edificio Residencial el ataque
tuvo lugar en la ciudad de saporía urbe
bajo control ucraniano a pesar de ser la
capital de una de las cuatro regiones
anexionadas unilateralmente por Rusia en
septiembre del año pasado
continuamos con más información de la
guerra en Ucrania porque el año pasado a
medida que las fuerzas rusas se
retiraron de ciertas zonas que habían
ocupado previamente miles de cadáveres
de soldados rusos quedaron atrás desde
entonces a Pequeños grupos de
voluntarios ucranianos intentan
encontrarlos y enviarlos de vuelta a
Rusia este es un reportaje de nuestros
equipos sobre el terreno pero les
advertimos que este informe contiene
imágenes que algunos pueden encontrar
perturbadoras
Ese es su indicativo militar necesitan
cruzar este pantano para llegar a los
restos de un soldador ruso
los hombres dicen que su cámara diría
ayuda porque su trabajo es sombrío
recoger los cadáveres enemigos que yacen
por la región de harquip después de un
kilómetro llegan al lugar
venimos aquí antes y nos llevamos todos
los cuerpos que pudimos cargar ahora
hemos vuelto por el quinto como pueden
ver no queda mucho de él estaba herido
tiene torniquetes en las piernas solo la
mitad del cuerpo está aquí los perros
probablemente se comieron la otra mitad
o lo arrastraron
con los primeros cuerpos que encontramos
por supuesto que tuvo una reacción
emocional como la tendría cualquiera
pero una vez que has cargado con 100 o
más las emociones desaparecen
todos los cuerpos que hemos encontrado
estamos dispuestos a entregarlos a
cambio de los nuestros solo imploro a
sus familiares que inicien un movimiento
de protesta
la esperanza es que una mayor conciencia
sobre el elevado número de víctimas
pueda conducir a un menor apoyo a la
guerra en Rusia sin embargo los
principales objetivos de la recogida de
cadáveres son impedir que contaminen el
medio ambiente aportar pruebas para
futuros juicios por crímenes de guerra y
lo que es más importante
intercambiarlos por los cuerpos de
soldados ucranianos primero los llevamos
a la morgue después del proceso de
identificación los llevamos a los
vagones
este vagón de ferrocarril contiene
actualmente 10 cadáveres de soldados
rusos serán intercambiados dentro de
unos días
qué siento por ellos
no siento nada son cadáveres y ya está
ya ha recogido a más de 400 rusos
muertos Aunque dan cientos más por
encontrar solo en la región de harquis
en otras Noticias al menos cuatro
personas murieron y nueve resultaron
heridas en una avalancha en los alpes
franceses esto según anunció el ministro
del interior de Francia la prensa
francesa informa que las víctimas
estaban de caminata por las montañas y
que no hubo alerta de avalancha según el
periódico lemont probablemente el calor
y el viento precipitaron el fenómeno
y hace exactamente 20 años en el marco
de la invasión estadounidense de Irak
las tropas de Washington tomaron la
capital Bagdad y derrocaron el régimen
de Sadam husein Ramiro cué Barberena con
la historia
la plaza fue escenario de un momento
histórico un 9 de abril pero de 2003 las
fuerzas estadounidenses entraron en
Bagdad la capital de Irak como parte de
su operación para desbaratar el presunto
armamento de destrucción masiva del país
árabe y que terminó con el derrocamiento
del régimen basista una jornada de
emborrable para los ciudadanos que
estuvieron en la plaza cuando las tropas
invasoras derrumbaron la Estatua de San
hussein ese día estaba con un grupo de
personas en la plaza firdaos estábamos
parados allí con un ojo llorando y otro
sonriendo un ojo se reía porque nos
deshicimos del régimen dictatorial y el
otro ojo lloraba porque vimos la
realidad de los tanques estadounidenses
en la plaza firdaos significa que eso
era ocupación
sin embargo lo que en un momento fueron
ilusiones por la caída del régimen
dictatorial de Sadam derivó en
desencanto por las consecuencias de la
ocupación estadounidense
esperábamos que la comunidad
internacional salvara al pueblo
iraquídeambre que hubiera un cambio real
a través de medios constitucionales o
legales un cambio Pacífico pero lo que
vino con la ocupación fue deliberado
colapso del Estado a través de la
disolución de las instituciones
militares la destrucción de las
instituciones gubernamentales y otras
administraciones
la toma de Bagdad la cual no encontró
grandes oposiciones para las tropas de
Estados Unidos abrió nuevos problemas en
Irak con el levantamiento de Rebeldes
militares una guerra civil sectaria y la
llegada posterior del estado islámico
sigan con nosotros
[Música]